[Music]
[Music]
hallo YouTube just loves my friends this
is guns in here and I like to welcome
you all for this interesting chess
opening episode against Sicilian after E
for probably the most dangerous and
testing reply is C Phi known as Sicilian
defense and it is one of the most
complex opening and because there are
many variation and sub variation exists
sometimes it is very difficult to cope
up with the theory especially to create
your own recruit ah again straight now
the opening system I am going to
recommend in this video not only can be
applied to any Sicilians but the best
part I found about it it's very flexible
and white can choose which side he wants
to play like King side Queen side or in
the center the good news is there is no
clear definition of this line so you can
use it on regular basis or a complete
surprise weapon in the two now and
practice okay so without a further due
let's get started
first I'm going to illustrate the
structure of this opening and then we
will see three different games on
different side of the ball
which will give you a broad idea how you
can play confidently the second move
what is going to play is c4 and this
opening is based on controlling the d5
square as we all know that all the
Sicilian players want to achieve this
traumatic defy break which we are going
to prevent throughout the game now I'm
going to show you
only white move which will give you
where exactly the pieces are belong and
then what is the middle game plan here
most likely we are going to continue it
Knight to c3 controlling the D fast
more then comes the fourth piece which
controls the d5 square namely g3 and
Bishop to g2 and after that the rest of
the army developed like this we are
going to play d3 liberating the other
bishop then comes Knight G to e2
afterwards comes a very important point
if your opponent has played the Moon
Knight to f6 then you really don't want
to play Bishop to e3 immediately as it
can be kicked away with Knight to g4 so
in that case why it should play this
prophylactic move s3 in order to play
the move Bishop to e3 next or to castle
on the Kings side well you can choose
either of the move but I like to be
remain very flexible so the setup I'm
going to recommend start with Bishop to
e3 afterwards our queen will go on to
the D 2 square so in the case where
black has fianchetto his Bishop this
Queen Bishop battery is very useful to
exchange the dark square bishop well
afterwards most likely what is going to
castle on the King side and as the
opening stage is finished as two rooks
are connected and our King is safe now
comes the big question what we are going
to do in the middle game well here I
have highlighted three different plants
and depending on your preferences you
can play it in the game if you like to
attack on the King side then the
simplest plan is you go ahead with the
move f/4g for coming forward with your
pawn on the Kings side followed by
Knight to g3 and a good King side attack
many times what will happen is black is
not going to be careful against this
opening as this is very rare guests so
they lose the control on the d4 square
and that's where you have to be very
alert
what is going to achieve the break d4
and then transpose the game in the rims
of marcozzi bind last but not least y
can also play on the queenside with the
moves such as rook to be 1 and then a 3
and B 4 and get a very aggressive play
on that side of the ball so that's it
guys that is in the nutshell in terms of
opening if you just look at for the few
times you will literally memorize this
model and then you are all set to play
this opening with conference well now I
like to show you three games where we
are going to see how White has achieved
his Trump on three different side of the
ball in the first game I like to show
you how white can generate a queen side
of Jack so as I mentioned earlier the
opening goes very smoothly and in fact
very effectively
efore C Phi do you remember yup the
second move c4 we are going to control
on the d5 square here a black continues
with Knight to c6 afterwards yup like to
c3 putting more control on the D Phi
square and black continue with one of
the most famous set up against this line
namely start with g6
ok no shoes we are going to continue
with g3 Bishop to g7 Bishop to g2 and
now black liberate his other bishop with
the moon d6 kind of a dragon structure
but it doesn't matter to us as our piece
layout is very much fixed we are going
to continue with Knight G 2 e 2 and
after the moon ecigs
yes white can continue it D 3 but in
this game he preferred to castle first
and after the Moon Knight G to e7 d3 is
a usual response here but as we are
going to see some Queen side action in
this game
white prefer to delay that move and
immediately consider this move namely
looked to be one and after castle on the
Kings side as I mentioned earlier this
effective plan of campaign comes into
the picture immediately with a 3 B 6 and
now before if black captured on before
then it will lose the control on the d4
square and that we are going to see in
the next game but in this game black
wisely avoid the exchange and continue
with Bishop to d7
well that doesn't interrupt of a plan we
are going to continue it d3 liberating
at the bishop and after Knight to d4
which in fact many theory book recommend
the key point you have to remember here
that this night is belonged to the e7
square not on f6 so that's why we don't
want to play h3 but instead of that we
are going to continue with Bishop to e3
as it cannot be harassed by the night ok
black continue with rook to b8 and now
the thematic expansion on the King side
f4 grabbing every single space on the
Kings side black continue with f5 so
stopping any nuisance on that side of
the board
afterwards white played a sneaky move
Bishop to f2 so if required then on the
right time white can remove that
dangerous night now black in this game
completely unaware of what is happening
on the ball and continue with this
casual move and in fact this is many
times happen against this open
your opponent doesn't realize the danger
in this position and suddenly just
within two to three moves he get a loss
position in fact this is the case here
as after the move Queen to c8 wide give
black this ultimate shock Knight
captures d4 pawn captures d4 and now
Knight to be fire and what else
black is in a huge trouble well he tried
the move defy
but after C kept his defy he kept his
defy and the move ePHI all the threat
remain as it is and on top of everything
after the move Queen to d7 white even
doesn't bother about taking upon he
plunk is knight on a juicy b6 square and
telling black you are in a big trouble
might well game finished very quickly
black plays Bishop too weird but after
Queen to b3 putting pressure on this two
pawns black decided to defend on d4 but
I think this is a big time in accuracy
as after Bishop captures defy King to h8
and night to have seven check black
simply resign in the view of the simple
threat King to g8 and now there are many
good discoveries but I think the easiest
way to play this position is give the
discover check with Knight to d8 and
after King to h8 Knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes Queen takes and now
sting in the tail Bishop captures ePHI
and if you carefully look at this
position white is clearly to pawn up and
black doesn't have a single compensation
forage so I think this model game will
give you a good idea how to play this
opening aggressively on the queenside in
the second game we are about to see how
white can achieve his team attic break
d4 if black is not careful and if you
get a good center then again the full
point is waiting on the board he for C
Phi C for controlling the d5 square
Knight to c6 Knight to c3 g6 g3 Bishop
to g7 Bishop to G to d6
night ii ii ii ii 6 castle on the Kings
side and after the Moon Knight G to e7
in the last game we have look at the
move rook to be one following up with
quick a 3 and B 4 in this game
white continued the usual setup namely
d3 and after castle on the Kings side
now I'd played the moon III ok-hee 6
rook to be one it's very important to
take that rook out of that diagonal as
sooner or later we are going to continue
with b4 and in that case this move is
very handy well black just copy white he
continued 8th rook to b8 and now I play
the move b4 which in fact this time
black took it okay white recaptures
black plays B Phi I took it black to kid
and now compared to the last game you
can see the big difference there is no
control on the d4 square so that means
it allow white to play this expansion
move d4 grabbing tremendous center and
space in the center of the ball well
black doesn't like it so he continued
with F Phi trying to destroy the white
wonderful Center
but no matter after he kept us fi Luke
kept us Fi and now the star mu yup defy
and it is conformed after this moon that
black will have a permanent weakness on
the d6 square he captures defy Knight
captures defy King to h8 getting out of
any future checks but white is more than
happy as he already created weakness so
he continued with night capture c7
Knight captures a 7 and night to d4
attacking on the rook rook to f7 and now
it's just a matter of activating the
rest of the army so white continue of it
look to even grabbing the open file
Queen to f8 hitting on f2 but wide
defend elegantly with Bishop 12 for
counter attacking the loose d6 square ok
black continue with Bishop to a5
attacking white rogue but white is more
than happy as that Luke was not doing on
even softer look to Sivan at least that
rook has been activated here black
should have played the moon rook to b6
but even after that blacks position will
remain very passing so black come up
with this idea rook to d8 defending on
d6 and getting out of the pain but the
meantime what he forgot is white can
simply take on b5 and now there are
three attackers on d6 which is not easy
to stop knight to see it happen on the
board
defending on d6 but now why push the
fifth gear with Bishop to g5 attacking
on the rogue and unfortunately that rope
doesn't have any good space to hurt if
Luke to d7 then Bishop to c6 is a very
strong reply so in the game black played
the move
to have six which in fact turnout has a
big-time disaster well before I move on
I like you to pause this video and find
out a sequence where white immediately
get a winning advantage let's see the
first move is very obvious Bishop
captures up six rook captures up six and
now this thematic move Queen to d4
pinning down the rook the only good way
to unpin this rookie's Queen to g7 but
this allowed a nasty finish hit rook to
c7 and now that Queen can no longer
defend or have sex in the game black
tried the move Bishop to d7 blocking the
diagonal but he get this rude shock boom
ha ha ha ha
and funny enough black loses a piece
instantly with a completely hopeless
position last but not least now we are
going to witness the game against the
Kings side which in fact as for the
database more common in this opening
efore C Phi c4 Knight to c6 Knight to c3
g6 g3 Bishop to g7 Bishop to G to d6
Knight G to E 2 and instead of the last
two game where black continue with c6 in
this game black continue with
immediately rook to be intention is very
simple he wants to play a 6 B Phi and
grab every single space on the Queen
side well no problem
white continue with castle on the Kings
side and after the move a 6
if your opponent is playing on the
queenside we are more than happy to play
on the kingside as if he's going to win
there probably he will get a piece but
if he win on the Kings side we will get
the King black continue with Bishop to
d7 and I really like White's next move
which is in fact very common once you
are concentrating on the King side it is
very important to block you open to tack
on the Queen side and accordingly
a4 is a fitting reply stopping any
expansion on the Queen side well black
continue with the theoretical move
Knight to d4 but this is not helping him
as he is moving the same pieces twice
wide response is very obvious d3
liberating the dark squared bishop and
accordingly black hurry up to castle on
the Kings side with night two at six now
here Bishop to e3 is not a good idea the
simple reason is if your opponent has
knight on f6 or at six then he can kick
our Bishop with Knight to g4 so that's
why white find a very good idea
he continued with f5 sacrificing a pawn
for a great attack on the Kings side
well black accept the challenge and he
take this pawn afterwards white reveal
his trump namely Knight to f4 so as you
can see that Knight is going on reg Phi
where if allowed then he will definitely
take on the g7 Bishop black played
Knight to c6
so his idea is very simple when white
played the move Knight to H Phi he's
going to give this check and after King
to h8 he wants to play this furious move
Knight to g4 so not only at this point
black is apana but black has some thread
going on and it seems like white
position doesn't have a punch after
sacrificing upon
well sometimes the perception can be
deceptive and here as the blacking is
stuck in the center white is more than
happy to do an exchange sacrifice with
this beautiful moon he captures fi
creating a space for his minor piece
obviously black was more than happy as
he continued with night 2 f2 so white
responds his force white has to take
this night and after Bishop captures f2
yes indeed
black emerged with an exchange job but
just after few moves you can see the
pitiable position for the black well
black fund has come to the end and now
actually it is white who is having all
kind of threads
starting with Knight to g7 King to her
fate is forced afterwards second forcing
move Bishop to at six simple idea if the
King doesn't move then Knight to e6 will
nab the Queen so in the game black
continued with King to g8 but after just
one move black resigns so before I move
on last time guys I'm asking you pause
this video and find out a move which
force black to instantly give up the
game well I hope you find this decisive
blow BAM so white knight is attacking on
the Queen and the funny thing is Queen
cannot move as after Queen to g4 black
King as a complete corner and if black
continued with grabbing this Knight then
even that doesn't stop white as Queen to
g4 leads to the mate you want me to show
you okay let me do it very quickly
King to f7
Quinn to g7 kinky weird Quinn captures
rook king f7 Quinn g7 check and the
final move
yup Quinn to FH good night sweet case to
the black camp that's it guys with these
three games I hope you get enough
confidence to play this line instantly
in your own game well apart from this I
have also included a database in the PGN
which covered more games of this line
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
on this and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care